[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's poppin so today we are going to
talk about internships yes we talk about
this all the time but I love talking
about it so today we are going to talk
about what are the top 10 software
engineering internships you can get now
top internship is really subjective you
know some people like for example Apple
for Google some people like Google over
Apple so you don't really know it's kind
of subjective and also there's a lot of
things to consider like salary benefits
prestige you know some people it's all
about the and then how much you learn
and then also the team and also the
technology that they use some people
care about that
some people don't so you know so it's
kind of hard to consolidate all these
together and come up with good answer
until now so there's this guy in
Waterloo that's great
LinkedIn you know scrape the whole
website looked at all you want to lose
students and basically what he did is he
looked at every single student and their
history of internships that he did now
Waterloo makes you do six internships so
basically he made an assumption that
your last internship is better than your
before last internship so for example if
their first internship was Google and
then their next internship was Apple he
would deem Apple better than Google now
that's just one person so he did that
with everyone
you know he did that with every single
you Waterloo kid and basically gave an e
low score to every one of these
companies so now I'm just gonna use this
website and I'm going to sort it by
dizzy low score before I go into the top
town let me just show you what this site
is all about this I think this site is
kind of down now and I kind of just kept
a copy for myself so so here's what it
looks like as you can see every row is a
person so if you sit it out you know you
see that this guy went to clear bridge
associated then TD Securities then said
they'll so that means that that would be
better than all these
companies and encode Connect would be
better than Citadel oh that's me that's
actually me
I guess the data wasn't very updated and
I could clearly say that say that though
is better than sorta Bank by far anyway
so this is what it looks like and then
when you aggregate all this you get this
with new law I don't know why we can't
sort I mean usually you can't sort but I
think it's because the person thin they
probably didn't do the department didn't
scrape the JavaScript so I have like an
old version so what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna copy all that and like
as a true data scientist I'm just gonna
use Excel you know I was thinking like
maybe parsing in or something but screw
that I'm just gonna use Excel because it
seems like it's well formatted so all
right the name copy open up Excel and
voila okay cool and then put a filter
here filter and then sort descending so
I'm not gonna tell you which company's
first yet so I'm gonna blur it out here
I'm just gonna blur to top 10 and as you
can see okay maybe I'll start from the
bottom you know so you guys no spoilers
so you know for example EA is ranked
number 24 you got square number 22 and
then Bloomberg 21 you can see it's
sorted but they're a low score yeah and
then okay I'm gonna blur out the top
with the top ten it makes a lot of sense
all right let's start number 10 we have
Microsoft you still working for
Microsoft so you still working for
Microsoft so yeah Microsoft is still
pretty good then you know as not bad not
gonna lie Microsoft's a pretty good
company it's just that for me or for my
um some of my friends we just like to
joke around that Microsoft is like it
and company is like a low tier company
but it's not Microsoft is a great
company the only reason we do that is
because
have to make fun of one company and
Microsoft is so big such that if I make
fun of them they wouldn't care because
I'm so small but yeah this is great
because I'm able to talk about Microsoft
okay so Microsoft is known to have
pretty easy interviews I have done their
interview for software engineering and
for program manager and I'd like to say
that their software engineering
interview was pretty easy I passed in
one shot so so the software engineering
interview is quite simple for me at
least they came to Waterloo and I had
two interviews back-to-back and then
after those two interviews they'll say
you get the internship or not so the
first question I got was a little bit of
a design question with like databases or
the infrastructure basically what
they're saying is that you know if you
send a certain message to a certain
server and they have to send it back and
stuff like that but what if if like
those messages get lost what would you
do for fault tolerance and stuff like
that it's a little bit of a design
question and then the second question is
super easy link list question it's stuff
like can you find out if the link list
has a loop or something like that and
then is there another way you can do it
I'm not gonna go over details but
basically it's two questions alright
second thing I want to talk about is the
salary for me I think the salary for me
was like seven thousand dollars a month
and then you get sick housing actually
housing is kind of a gamble sometimes
you might get better housing sometimes
not because they just put entrance
everywhere for me I was able to go into
like a hotel I think it was like the
Hyatt Hotel and it's pretty dope cause
you got maid service every single day so
yes the benefits were pretty good all
right let me double check the salary
real quick Microsoft yeah so Microsoft
is seven point two thousand dollars per
month and then they give you one point
three thousand dollars for housing or
you choose their corporate housing
obviously choose a corporate housing
because it's way better but yeah seven
point two thousand that's not bad that's
not bad yeah I'll show you at the end
the list like this salary list and later
on but I don't wanna you got to stay
through this whole video just check it
out
all right cool on to the next one on the
list number nine it is yep at an
interview of Yelp for software
engineering
their interview I would rate it a bit
harder than Microsoft you know I pass in
one shot too but they had a lot of
interviews okay I think on site I had
two on-site interviews and then two
phone interviews later to confirm that I
was in you know just lucky and very
standard interview questions and then
they also look at your projects a little
bit so I think what I showed them is I
showed them a project that you could
sink watching YouTube together they were
pretty impressed by that and then a lot
of like normal questions normal like get
algorithm questions that you get all
neat code so then the phone screen is
also just coding you know that you go on
code pad they ask you a question and
then you code it so I think their
interview process is a little bit harder
and they don't accept like that many
people let's talk about a salary so Yelp
is seven point six thousand dollar per
month plus one point five thousand
dollars per housing if you don't do
Corpening that is pretty good I think
Yelp is Yelp is usually hired in like
Google and Microsoft because they're a
little bit smaller so they have to stay
competitive by giving you more money so
yeah so the salary is pretty damn good
and then prestige yeah I think Yelp is
pretty much mid tier like okay honestly
don't don't take my word for granted but
I'm just like comparing to all the next
ones that we're gonna see but Yelp Yelp
is like not like super high tier but
it's also not like super low tier it's
kind of like with Microsoft same level
as Microsoft in terms of like prestige
and in terms of how much you're gonna
get next company is Pinterest to be
honest I don't know why this isn't
higher it might be just variants to be
honest because there aren't that many
people that got into Pinterest because
the total number of students that got
there or like at least scraped it was
only seven I do think that the princess
is pretty high up there cuz I heard from
a lot of people Pinterest is like one of
the smartest companies like every time
you go to Pinterest people say like wow
I've worked with like the smartest
people so yeah I think Pinterest should
be a little bit higher up it might be
just variance like I said alright let's
check Pinterest Oh
so how hard is the interview I don't
know I actually don't have a because
I've never interviewed with Princess so
I wouldn't know so I can't tell you that
okay and then how good the salary is all
right you ready the salary is $9,000 a
month and then $3,000 per housing so
that makes it like $12,000 a month then
that crazy so yeah so definitely because
of the salary people do want to work at
Pinterest all right next company I have
here infusion hmm I'm actually not
familiar with this company let me google
it real quick
or maybe it is a really good company I
don't know but I don't have I mean if
you guys know please comment below if
you know infusion and what their
reputation is but I don't quite know
because there's a lot of there's a lot
of other good companies that didn't make
the list I'll give some spoilers Amazon
did not make the top 10
LinkedIn did not make the top ten
squared anomic the top 10 but they're
all super good companies it's possible
that a lot of smart people maybe got
into these companies and then they just
got bored so they want to work for
startups and then it'll decrease your
deal oh that's just how it works but
yeah all right company number six ooh
speaking of Amazon I wonder if you can
guess which one this is so a company
number six it is a nine comm so in case
you guys don't know what a nine calm is
subsidiary of Amazon a nine I think it's
more like the research focus part a more
data-driven part so I think they do like
a lot of the search functionality of
Amazon and all the hard stuff the hard
problems so I had an interview of 89 I
should twice actually and I got rejected
twice so the first time yeah I'm not
gonna lie it I think it was pretty hard
I don't remember what the question was
but I think it was really a dynamic
programming and I think it took me some
time to write it and then they also have
like a design question I think it's like
something related to like either
horizontally scaling or vertically
scaling I think it was like a
distributed question but basically I
didn't do so well and then the second
I had the same interviewer and I think I
did well because like it was the same
question but they still didn't take me
so I think it's because I was being a
dick I was like yeah I was there before
yeah whatever you know I think I think
they just don't like me so so how good
is this salary let me check
oh well then again I wouldn't know
because I didn't get the job so but
let's look at Amazon so Amazon give you
seven point six thousand dollars a month
and two point five thousand dollars so
that's pretty average so I guess it's
average average salary I don't think it
would be much different from Amazon so I
think that's that's a good estimate of
what a nine interns would get seven
point six thousand okay
and then terms of prestige it's kind of
similar to like it's like Yelp and it's
like above Yelp and Microsoft definitely
definitely below Pinterest so I think
that's a prestige level especially in
Waterloo like it's pretty good but it's
not like whoa Oh number five
Google classic Google I mean everyone
loves to work at Google a lot of like
really smart people can get to Google
early on but they also like to come back
to Google at the end because the company
is so big you could choose which team to
go in some people like to work for it's
very specific team at Google some people
sometimes if you're not like super great
at programming or you're not like a
prodigy but you can still get to Google
because they're so big such that they
accept a lot of interns so prestige
level I would say pretty high you know
but nowadays it's getting more and more
easy to get into Google and so I think
that's what your value is decreasing in
terms of like Waterloo internships so
the interview varies a lot so it really
depends what your interviewer is I
perceive never gone to Google I did I I
did a few interviews I choked not a lot
of like dynamic programming questions or
anything some of them can be simple I
heard some of them can be hard it really
depends so a lot of bearings bear now
the salary is pretty [ __ ] to be
I think the reason they can do that is
because everyone loves Google so they
pay you six point six thousand dollars
per month and then maybe three thousand
dollars for housing per month so that
makes it maybe nine point six thousand
but yeah your face salary isn't that
great because it's only six point six
thousand so yeah and then my friends who
worked at Google they said it was pretty
chill to be honest they don't work you
that hard and even once you're full-time
if you don't want to you could go in
teams that don't work really really hard
and that but Google is really good to
work there because later on you know you
have a super comfortable life company
number for Facebook Facebook Oh Facebook
so yeah I've never worked as a software
engineer at Facebook can I even say that
my friends who work at Facebook said
they loved it you know they have a great
campus beautiful campus
lots of prestige kind of yeah but it's
getting bigger and once a company gets
bigger obviously they lose prestige and
stuff like that but yeah so the salary
for Facebook interns for software
engineering is eight thousand dollars
and one thousand dollars for housing so
in total nine thousand dollars I'm
surprised actually that's quite that's
quite low for housing and then Facebook
is really good because when you come
back as a returning intern if you do
really well you get more stocks and like
bonus and stuff like that so on average
according to this chart is like one
hundred seven thousand dollar salary you
get about thirty seven point five
thousand dollars of stocks per year and
then your bonus can vary from 75,000 to
$100,000 in bonus but that means your
first year you just boom on three
thousand dollars right in your bank
account so yeah so that puts Facebook on
number four and then number three is
Twitter
all right so Twitter is number three
Twitter is surprisingly not that high in
terms of salary I'll talk about that
later how hard is the interview I
remember interviewing for Twitter for
software engineer or data science that
I'll remember
and I had a phone screen and with that
phone screen I felt I'm so I'm guessing
Twitter's pretty hard you know because I
felt the phone screen but but then again
you know maybe I just suck so by
according to other people I think
Twitter's is also pretty average I don't
see a lot of people getting into Twitter
so I think Twitter is pretty like pretty
difficult in terms of like the interview
not super super hard also not you know
not super easy but yeah so that's how
hard the interview is so I can't really
tell you anything about that
the phone screen that I hat was a
dynamic programming question that I
screwed up how good is the salary the
salary is pretty [ __ ] actually it's six
point five thousand dollars per month
and they give you $2,000 for housing or
maybe get up corporate housing I'm not
sure yeah and then prestige I think it's
I think it's pretty up there I mean for
some reason they're losing popularity
nowadays I mean also this list is kind
of old but yeah Twitter's losing
popularity so maybe not that much all
right number two okay so I realize I've
been doing this wrong this should be
number one
so I started number ten but I realize my
excel sheet it starts out one but then
the first row of my excel sheet it says
company name so that means I include the
header but okay so for the number one
company I would choose I would choose
one company out of all of these and then
yeah so it's basically Ole Miss first
coming all right anyway so number two
company is Palantir technologies oh I I
think Palantir is actually the coolest
company because I've tried so many times
getting into college here and I still
haven't gotten in yet so the first time
I had an interview was when I was when I
was freshman year actually I got really
lucky because like I talked to this guy
and he just gave a talk about Palantir
and he was from Montreal and I was like
oh me too I'm from Montreal and then you
know he was nice enough to give me an
interview and then I got that phone
screen the phone screen was actually
pretty hard it was um well at least I
think it was pretty hard it was like
print a binary search tree in order or
something like
left to right and that was that whole
easy I wrote the recursion and they say
all right now do it without recursion
like Nani and then yeah so basically you
had to you know you just had to make it
stack kind of like a kinda like a
recursion stack but basically you just
have to make a stack you had to loop it
in and then you pop the stack until
there's no more things to pop you could
search binary search tree in order
traversal without recursion and you'll
find it
and that's exactly what I did so it was
a full screen right and then what I did
was I secretly googled the answer and
went to the Wikipedia page and saw the
supernal code and then I just looked at
it and said oh wait I think I understand
and I just wrote the code perfectly for
them yeah so that's that and that's how
I got past it but then after that I went
on site and then the guy talked to me he
looked at my resume he's a how the [ __ ]
does this guy get in and then he asked
me like a design question and yeah I
just screwed up cuz I didn't know
anything back then I was just a kid so I
didn't know anything about - first
chakra I only knew about algorithms so
yeah so I got killed mmm okay it's not
that great so yeah the salary is seven
point four five thousand dollars per
month flat that's it and then you have
to pay for your own housing and
something that so it's not that best I
think this company has a lot of prestige
especially back then everyone was
wearing these like dope ass black
sweaters by Palantir and everyone felt
really cool working there I'm not gonna
lie it was a little bit cult issue
according to some my friends but in a
good way
so yeah and I remember people telling me
that their food was amazing to have like
salmon you know like a really nice girl
time they have like really good chefs to
make food they have massages you know at
their campus so yeah so they usually
have things like for deployed engineers
and normal software engineers and stuff
like that for deploy is pretty cool
because it means you get to travel and
you've met you get to you get to talk of
clients and then you know fix your [ __ ]
or whatever but yeah it's a really cool
company and makes you feel really badass
because they're like gods with data
that's basically what pound here is oh
yeah for those who don't know Palantir
technology is basically like a Dana
consulting company like they don't say
they're consulting company you say
technology company but in the end I
think they're a consulting company what
they do is like they help the government
like track down Osama bin Laden they
help they help like some some government
stuff to like track down disease and
stuff like that they probably like do a
lot of sketchy stuff that we don't know
about because they're like they're just
really good of data they help hospitals
and stuff like that for for processing
and analyzing their data what else
something more interesting
oh they help a lot of hedge funds and
banks do some financial stuff that we
can't talk about because they're so
secretive all right
so number one according to my
spreadsheet it's company name yeah all
right let me just look at the one that
pays the most I would say that they're
number one hmm
okay there's a lot wait where's change
Street oh no Jane tree is not here wait
mm yeah okay so Jane shade should be
here but I guess it's not anymore but
you could kind of know where I'm going
with this okay and I'll just choose this
one well I don't really want to choose
it cuz my brother worked there and I
don't want him to feel proud of it okay
forget I'll just choose it all right so
the number one company it is two sigma
for you guys who don't know two sigma is
a hedge fund it's it's a very
quantitative based hedge fund meaning
that use a lot of tech and it uses a lot
of numbers to kind of like decide on
what stocks to trade or what commodities
to trade and stuff like that so they're
known to be pretty techie you don't like
the finance kind of vibe or like
appliance culture people are not like
jocks they're people are like pretty
cool like it basically looks like it
looks like a typical tech company when I
went there and visited so the reason why
I chose is because the pretty high
salary is ten point four thousand
dollars a month and then they give you
$5,000 for relocation and then they give
you $5,000 per month for housing what
the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that's crazy that's
more than how much I make as a full-time
[ __ ] but yeah and the bonuses I heard
they're crazy like once you've worked
out full-time bonuses are amazing and
yeah you wouldn't believe it
so basically all these finance companies
should be here in case you guys don't
know it's not fin tech because fin tech
means a technology company that is about
financial products like they help you
you know manage your portfolio blah blah
that's not it
they use tech so that they can so that
they can grab a [ __ ] ton of data and
then just make a lot of money in the
stock market or whatever that they trade
so it's totally different than fin tech
technologies but you can't compare it to
like like Robin Hood you know it's not
the same thing but yeah so two sigma
Citadel of Jane Street like um
sis Gahanna SSI cube no decide sis
Kahana
red sauce technology actually we can't
talk about Renaissance too much because
that's just at another level so we that
just like we don't understand what he do
but yeah so all of these are really
really good hedge funds and they
probably pay the most compared to like
other tech companies so yeah alright so
now let me talk about oh wait so yeah so
two sigma or stage hello hi it's funny
because it wasn't that high before what
my brothers started I remember me
telling my friends I hope my brother
works s to sit there like what the [ __ ]
is that
Oh Michael it's a finance companies like
a home finance is it banker or something
like no it's not a bankers a qualitative
researcher but anyways 2 Sigma was not
really popular but nowadays because of
the emergence of all these finance
companies and then they realized I hold
you should they pay a lot it got the
attention of the software engineers so
so yeah so now prestige definitely high
prestige people love to Sigma they think
it's they think it's like the best thing
since sliced bread so yeah pretty good
alright and interview is probably super
hard if it's the same or if it's similar
to the full time interview a lot of
probability questions a lot of
qualitative questions a lot of
Statistics questions a lot of brain
teasers
lots of hard CS questions
I mean I don't know I never got an
interview from them so I wouldn't know
but yeah that's what I heard there are a
lot of companies that did not make the
top 10 list don't know why probably
because we just don't have that much
data like I said this this set is not
super super good because it's still kind
of hacky but let me tell you a few
companies that I think deserves you know
to share the number one spot one of them
is snapchat of course
come on snapchat is great snapchat such
a great company it's also in LA so
that's pretty dope they have a New York
office - they paid $10,000 a month so I
think snapchats really good Cora Cora is
extremely hard to get in really smart
people they pay eight point three
thousand dollars a month and then let's
see twitch twitch is super fun you know
you get to get to watch people play
games all day and then they pay you 7.4
thousand dollars a month then Airbnb
Airbnb is really good too they pay
$7,000 a month plus corporate housing
and they give you some Airbnb credit
super cool and 'red dog friendly one of
my friends yeah I'm one of my friends
interim there and he got to bring his
dog everyday I see our strike is really
good stripes is really good $7,000 a
month plus corporate housing definitely
good company it's about payments let's
see
Dropbox of course Dropbox is really good
I'm surprised their their salary so low
six point three thousand dollars per
month plus five thousand dollar house oh
I guess a five thousand dollar housing
is pretty good or a corporate housing
but I don't think any corporate house it
would be five thousand dollars maybe
that's a total I'm not sure so yeah yeah
that's pretty much it
I think these companies are definitely
really really good so if ever you have
the opportunities to to work there
definitely do it and yeah if ever you
guys are you know inundated by offers
from all these companies and you find it
really really hard to choose well I'm
going to link you guys the salary for
all these internships and also the site
that gives you like the e low and then
you could kind of compare and see which
one's better than which well so yeah I
hope that was interesting for you guys I
hope that was useful
the happy job hunting just remember if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
Like and subscribe and then also follow
me on Instagram at Joe mapa or any other
social media site you know whatever and
always peace out and see you tomorrow
you know you'd probably not get seen
tomorrow not going to make a video
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]